I first started watching South Park at
the second ering of the first episode
when I was but a we lad used to be South
Park would be on Wednesdays and
Saturdays the first Saturday ering I
watched it it made me laugh many times
over the years and it's made the libs
Furious many times over the years so we
will now examine the most triggering
scenes from South Park this is brought
to you by expressvpn go to
expressvpn.com more from them in a
second first now Matt and Trey take it
away
[Music]
you're so full of crap Foley what I did
shoot him in the face
twice ex excuse
me my name is Brad and I need to report
a crime anonymously oh what's the crime
well I attend South Park Elementary and
one of the teachers is having sex with a
student oh
my I remember this one you did the right
thing telling the police Brad Now who is
the teacher what's his name well it
isn't a guy teacher it's a woman a woman
yeah she's having sex with a
boy oh but but she's ugly right well no
not really it's the kindergarten teacher
Miss Stevenson the blonde yeah some
young boys having sex with Miss
Stevenson
yes nice nice what no you don't
understand it you sure they've had sex
yeah has she performed oral sex on him I
think
so nice nice nice
so wait what's the crime the crime is
she isn't doing it with
me hey he's totally underage she's
taking advantage of him you're right
we're sorry this is serious we need to
track this student down and give him his
luckiest boy in America metal right
away the story comes up every 6 months
some super good-look female teacher
sleeps with some usually teenage boy
that's bad and it's an abusive power and
they should be prose uted I'm not saying
otherwise but then there's that reaction
which is how dare you suggest that this
is any different from a male teacher
doing something like this with a female
student who's a teenager and you think
well no it it's different right I'm not
saying it's excusable or good in anyway
but boys and girls are different right
boys and girls react differently and
have different experiences especially of
sex and so
like it it is different right the
allegations against me are true over the
past several weeks I have been having
physical relations with one of my
students nice nice alcohol is a crutch
which we use to medicate ourselves to to
cover up emotional baggage from our past
was there ever a history of sexual abuse
in your family no but my uncle used to
ask me and my twin sister to kiss and
he'd take
pictures nice okay yeah there there it
is that's sort of the yeah it is that is
bad and you do see that reaction well it
is always that reaction you're like no
where were these teachers when I was in
school but the thing is to quote the
great late philosopher nor McDonald sex
is a filthy shameful thing that's
obviously only meant for procreation no
no let's not get ahead of ourselves here
and so when you divorce sex from its
proper use and purpose uh things get
very bad even if the teacher is super
hot and even if the student is a man
when you want to protect your data
you've got to go to express vpn.com
YT as you know there are a lot of people
who want to look at what you are doing
online the government the isps the big
tech companies they all are digging into
your stuff and so you should use the
number one rated VPN on the market
expressvpn head on over there right now
we've got all sorts of great deals and
promos if you are a listener and a
viewer of this show do not wait you got
to go immediately over to express
VPN letter y letter T that is
expressvpn.com
YT today on a cold October night a small
town in Colorado stood up to New Jersey
and finally said go away our fortitude
was the inspiration for others and now
New Jersey is slowly receding back to
the desolate land from whence it came
our country is getting back to normal
and we owe it all to Osama been
[Music]
lad on this day let us all remember that
no people on this Earth are really
enemies only folks with
differences Tango's down Tango's down we
got
him I remember in 2001 when South Park
came back after 9/11 everyone was kind
of nervous about their 9/11 episode cuz
how do you handle dealing with I guess
the greatest American Tragedy ever to
occur they handled it so beautifully
because they turned it into a Bugs Bunny
kind of thing and they're really these
are very sharp Guys these are guys who
have been aware of politics and
extremely artistically Adept for a very
long time in fact one of the early Trey
Parker and Matt Stone projects before
South Park was a movie with Larry Elder
and Dennis Prager what if by Magic I
could suddenly have black
skin and I believe officer bar Brady
actually is based on Dennis Prager I
think Matt once said that oh PC
principal how are you today what are you
doing in the faculty bathroom you know I
think you and I got off on the wrong
foot the other day by all means please
keep your dick out you see I'm not going
to accept 4 days of detention and you're
going to apologize publicly for being so
strict to me and my friends at ski what
the are you talking about it's just
a request that's all see you around oh
you seem to have dropped something PC
principal what's this why this is a
little boy's
underwear why this is Butter's underwear
what PC principal you have Butters
underwear and
now oh my gosh it's got your DNA all
over it this certainly doesn't look good
for you I don't need to tell anyone
about this no I think we have an
understanding
kich what did you just say you mean
about keeping your dick out capiche
you're associating italian-americans to
intimidation tactics you better watch
your microaggressions bro okay look you
don't want to end up like the spokesman
for Subway do you did you just use a
term that excludes women from an
occupation okay let's back up did you
just say spokesman instead of
spokesperson when women are just as
capable of selling sandwiches as anyone
Are you purposely trying to use words
that assert your male privilege no I'm
sorry I was just trying to frame you for
raping Butters do you think
italian-americans and women are less
important oh God you dare to use words
that alienate two communities of people
who have to deal with verbal biases like
yours on a daily
basis that's what it's like it do be
like that it it do some people don't
think it'd be like it is but it do let's
not forget excuse me everyone hello
everyone can I have your attention
please we got results from the P&R scan
of Dr McCormack's remains and we now
know the cause of his death now we all
need to stay calm there is no reason to
panic but Kenny died of Co it's a new
variant the co Delta plus Rewards
program variant I don't watch South Park
that much anymore because I don't watch
much TV because I don't pay for cable or
anything like that but so I actually I
don't think I saw this entire season and
I am kind of getting a kick out of
Cartman being what appears to be a rabbi
of some sort or is he a no I guess not
they're in a church so he's some kind of
Pastor it was confusing cuz the the
Cartman hat kind of looked like a
yam everyone please we cannot
Panic h
yeah we're all out of 10 diapers oh God
we're all out of 10
[Applause]
diapers Co was obviously invented by
toilet paper companies to sell more
toilet paper this whole thing all of
this it's all about me yeah it's funny
it's not you know I like that they came
on the right side of Co all being really
ridiculous the early seasons of South
Park I sound like a guy talking about
his hipster band that he loves you know
the early stuff man before everyone got
into it that was the really good stuff
okay next one Stanley well do you want
to tell your father about what happened
at school
today um oh oh I flunked my math quiz no
the other thing what other thing what
happened at school today
oh the school shooting yes the school
shooting oh yeah some kids shot up the
school who shot up the school was it you
no did you get shot no oh well what's
this about failing a math
quiz Are you serious did you not hear
what your child said kids died at his
school sorry Sharon I why are you all
acting like this is normal what is wrong
with you Pete
oh is dark but that's a pretty good bit
this just the reaction was it you no
were you shot no okay yeah it is it it
sadly has has become normal I don't
think I'd seen that one I'm I'm
realizing thankfully because my very
young producer is choosing all the clips
it's all these new ones that I haven't
seen it's a great show little a little
uh vulgar with the language that's not
ideal but those guys they get they get a
fair bit they get more right than they
get wrong all right that's the show see
you next time scre guys I'm going
yeah